even though they commemorated the 67th
anniversary of the neckla or catastrophe
Palestinians sure have a lot to
celebrate this week not only did the
Vatican officially recognize a state of
Palestine Pope Francis is declaring to
Palestinian nuns as Saints sisters
Miriam body and Mary alfonsín Danelle
her thoughts lived in 19th century
Ottoman era Palestine and will be the
only modern day Palestinians to become
Saints and abide the Intifada Reagan
this news may come as a big surprise to
many folks who didn't know that
Palestinian Christians even exist even
though and I'll let you in on a little
secret here Jesus Christ was from
Palestine you know the birthplace of
Christianity so anyway here's what you
should know about Palestine s Christian
population they've always been an
essential part of the fabric of
Palestinian society and the collective
struggle against Israel's occupation but
the numbers of Palestinian Christians
have drastically dwindled take Bethlehem
for example the city of Jesus's birth in
1947 the year before Israel became a
state 85% of the city's population was
Christian today it's less than 20% in
Jerusalem the Christian population in
1947 was 19%
now it's 2% in fact today Christians
make up only about 2% of the population
of the occupied West Bank and less than
1% of the Gaza Strip so why have the
numbers of Christian Palestinians
decreased so much the simple answer the
occupation Israel's illegal military
occupation of Palestinian lands has
meant daily hardships for all
Palestinians including Christians we're
talking restrictions and movement
limited access to water and electricity
and a beleaguered economy in and around
Bethlehem for instance Israel has
imposed some 32 checkpoints roadblocks
dirt mounds and gates that limit how
Palestinians can move around the city on
top of that Christian and Muslim
Palestinians alike are denied access to
worship at their holy sites in
Jerusalem's Old City
that's because Israel forbids
Palestinians from the West Bank and Gaza
from even entering Jerusalem unless they
get a difficult to obtain permit as for
Christian Palestinians
living in Jerusalem a recent survey
found that more than half want to leave
81% believed the occupation is the
biggest challenge they face it's not
much better for the Palestinian
Christians who are citizens of Israel
either they suffer the same widespread
discrimination as other non-jews who are
a minority in the state including
employment housing and land ownership
there's actually more than 50 laws that
discriminate against Palestinian
citizens of Israel making them second or
third class citizens in their own
homeland so how do Palestinian
Christians feel about the news of their
new Saints aj+ visited the Christian
quarter of occupied East Jerusalem to
find out till Mosul TN okasada o Bashar
bhai karate says Hashanah Telamon and
not command it decide in 10 our life now
is very difficult a lot of you know
things that make you go away from the
church these I hope it will be a
positive effect to let people go to
church more often very animosity not
matter cool at MCAD vo those Indian had
a bar Dome came obsolete had a lesion
and all the blood so Palestine got its
first Saints and recognition of
statehood from the Vatican but will this
bring the Holy Land a step closer to
peace